here we go
[Music]
hey what's up my name is Tui and welcome
to a whole new season of making it big
the show where we take your favorite
foods and turn it Giant in this season
we are filming every single episode on a
virtual reality camera that is so cool
so if you see that my table is a little
warped right here that's why you can
watch the full VR episode with a
metaquest 2 in mega tasty that's our
virtual cooking world within Horizon
worlds or on Meadow Quest TV today I
have a very special guest come on out
friend is this Playhouse
it's Josh Lane hey how you doing
thank you so much for being here thank
you for having me okay this is a nice
kitchen by the way I kind of want this
from my house yeah well it's mine
anyways wow
I love it I invited you here because we
share a love for a specific something
you are absolutely right it is the best
thing ever gummy bear gummy bear gummy
bear how big how about this big oh like
this big yeah okay see that's that okay
it's too easy hold on since it's all so
easy for you to do this
okay how about this big honestly can't
promise you this big but I can
definitely try I'm just worried about
the three things so taste taste texture
texture and visual and visual all right
let's make it big
[Music]
this is all the gelatin that I will be
using this is flavored gelatin you know
like those little packets this is
actually about like 70 of those packets
so if you're in Hollywood and you're
looking for gelatin it's all right here
I'm sorry we also have two quarts of
unflavored gelatin because if I'm just
going to be using these alone it's not
going to turn the bear into a gummy it
will just basically be like a Jello bear
instead of a gummy bear over here we
have the mold so this is about two feet
long the art Department did an amazing
job so I have pineapple here I have lime
we're just gonna combine all of that
together and call it a fruit punch a
fruit punch gummy I'm gonna start off by
juicing up some limes for lime juice I
need about like a gallon of lime juice
so however many limes that would take me
oh juicy so let's see that wasn't even
[Music]
that was probably like one tablespoon
oh
damn I have
a lot of limes left to do
so here's my lime juice this is my mango
juice and here's my pineapple juice I am
going to or all of that in here I can
take a bath in here this is massive here
we go
whoa oh stay back say I don't want you
to inhale this don't breathe
[Music]
I got you
and this is only
half of the batch that we're doing
because I mean if we're gonna add the
whole thing it's just it's too much I'm
gonna go ahead and use this Bay whisk
whoa look at the colors this is pretty I
love how I can taste the air right now
it tastes really good let's do it
[Music]
oh look at the color and then our
pineapple juice it smells really really
good too I have to make sure to mix it
really really well to hydrate all the
gelatin in here if we don't it's not
going to set right I have my my friend
over here a tiny toy she's gonna tell me
some fun facts about gummy bears okay
let's hear it
apparently gummy bears were invented in
1922 by Haribo I didn't know that and
the gummy bear shaped was inspired by
European dancing bears I would like to
see those bears
foreign
[Music]
just told me something crazy so
according to Haribo the annual
production of the gold Bears lined up
all like next to each other it can wrap
around the globe 10 times that's
a lot of gummy bears
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
it smells so good exactly like a fruit
punch just hot hot fruit punch okay this
is the second batch here we go I feel
like whoa whoa whoa whoa
that could have been feeling bad I feel
like this is
um build a bear but I mean it is
Build-A-Bear right I need you guys will
help me out there okay I think I got it
whoa
whoa all right I hope jock will enjoy
this bear as much as I enjoy making this
bear now I am going to let this chill in
the fridge for 24 hours
[Music]
okay all alone I just feel like I need
to give it up a few Taps to really
ensure that it comes out also just
buying a little time because I'm really
nervous
ready
oh
my baby
like look at how big this is this is
probably half of my height so what's
that like three feet no two feet two and
a half feet packaging let's go
[Music]
This Is The Moment of Truth the giant
gummy bear is done and I think jock is
here he's going to freak when I show him
this why come on in
[Music]
yes yes ready I'm ready okay let's do
this oh it looks just like a Gucci hair
that is soft
you are the best did I okay so looking
at this did I pass yes is he big this is
so big oh look at the details you can
see like the eyes yeah nose can you
guess how big he is like how much does
he weigh at least 25 pounds maybe okay
yeah well Gilbert right here is 50
pounds 50 pounds oh my goodness are you
ready I am I think we should sacrifice
him oh that is that the word we're gonna
use we're going to
um we will experience experience
Gilbert let's experience Gilbert
foreign
yes yes this is enough
okay so it looks like a Gummy Bear yes
but we gotta find out if it tastes like
gummy bear
oh poor Gilbert Gilbert we returning him
to Gilbert Van Gogh here this is yours
okay imma just do this
all right let me cut me a little piece
off here
yeah that's a gummy bear it's really
good but from this point I think um
you've done what I asked you to do she
made it big
and we'll see you guys on the next
episode
make sure to share with nope nope nope
this is not a shareable size you're
right not a shareable size in the
comments below let me know what I should
make big next and I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]